chloé peine il est médecin urgentiste à
l'hôpital de creil membres du collectif
des médecins en cgt bonsoir loïc pen
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt
france je vais citer l'un de vos
confrères il dit que leur confinement
n'est pas la conséquence d'une épidémie
hors de contrôle comme le dit emmanuel
macron mais plutôt le résultat d'une
crise des capacités des hôpitaux
est ce que vous êtes d'accord évidemment
il a raison en fait on confine à parce
que cette maladie est plus grave que
d'autres elle ces maladies sérieuses ça
fait 35 morts
on a un million de personnes qui sont
décédées dans le monde
on a la même chose pour la tuberculose
ont convenu là ce qui nous pose problème
et je soutiens la mesure de confinement
parce qu'on n'a plus le choix
mais elle arrive parce que nous ne
sommes plus capables avec le système
hospitalier français tel qu'il a été
dégradée de prendre cette épidémie en
plus de tous les cas que nous avons
habituellement élevé qui n'est pas
encore arrivé
le cumul des deux pathologies donc c'est
une crise des hôpitaux qui ont cette
date 2 ne date pas d'hier
on le savait à la sortie du du premier
confinement qu'il fallait en tout cas
réorganiser est ce que les choses ont
progressé néanmoins selon vous ont pas
du tout est ce que les hôpitaux sont
toujours au même stade en termes de
personnel est et de l'est n'ont pas
seulement réanimation mais aussi dans
dans les services conventionnels
non la situation n'a pas bougé
on a toujours le mémoire de lee on a
refermé les verts on a toujours le même
nombre de clients en réanimation
enfin c'est pas compliqué l'allemagne à
15 me pour être au même niveau en france
il faudrait qu'on ait blues mundi sur
les populations
on en a cinq mille donc voilà on y est
on va pas être capable de gérer cette
épidémie et la politique de santé qui a
été menée depuis des années
ça fait ça fait c'était déjà sarkozy
s'était déjà hollande
il y avait déjà macron puisqu'il était
dans la commission attali les terres
mais
double andré désormais prises en un clic
et mènent la même politique cette
politique a pas fait c'est l'hôpital
public à la priver de sa capacité à
répondre aux épidémies
nous en subissons aujourd'hui les
conséquences et en fait c'est la même
politique qui continue c'est à dire que
nous avons de nouveau un budget un
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale qui demande lui 100 millions
d'euros d'économies temps encore alors
on écoute le gouvernement qui nous dit
on ne peut pas augmenter le nombre de
lits parce qu'il ya un virus en temps
normal 5 milice a suffi or vous l'avez
dit l'allemagne en a plus le japon et la
corée du sud qui eux ont plutôt bien
géré la crise on on a deux à trois fois
plus donc c'est une seliana un élément
qu'il va falloir revoir parce qu'on
n'est pas à l'abri d'une d'une autre
crise
on aura d'autres crises les temps les
pandémies on les attend de façon assez
régulière
pas seulement à cause des hollows qui
arriverait là on a eu tout histoire en
fait pour la belgique c'est un peu
oublié on a des armes et l'hôpital alors
on a des arbitres hôpital dans ses
capacités à répondre et tout de suite il
faut leur égard mais c'est à dire que
l'excusé qui consiste à dire on ne forme
pas des soignants quelques mois déjà
faudrait commencer à le faire pour pas
être surpris dans quelques années et ça
n'a pas été fait le début du
commencement de la formation parfaite
et puis en attendant on peut embaucher
tout de suite des agents de service
hospitalier des agents administratifs
pour libérer du poids de la logistique
les soignons pour libérer du poids des
ministres hâtif les soignants donc on a
plein de choses à faire et puis vous
citiez la corée du sud en particulier au
delà même de leurs capacités
hospitalières
évidemment c'est un point important
j'arrête pas de le dire mais ils ont
aussi une politique de tests qui étaient
efficaces nous c'est fini gatti c'est à
dire qu on se vante d'une massification
des tests mais il était fait
difficilement il y avait du délai les
résultats qu'a vendu trop tard et ça
avant vu la politique de traçage
totalement inefficace là encore il ya
une véritable organisation à voir
faire de véritables checkpoint sur les
ai pas de à l'entrée des centres
commerciaux à l'entrée des universités
avec des tests on a des tests rapides
maintenant on vient tout juste de les
commander ils sont pas encore
parfaitement disponibles on n'a commandé
que 5 millions les résultats sont cinq
en quinze minutes pardon voilà ce qu'il
faut mettre en place il faut pas
attendre que finalement les patients
deux fois plus contagieux au moment où
les résultats des tests pcr a rit oui
les médecins disent il faut mettre des
tests rapides comme vous le dites dans
les milieux où le virus circule et non
pas dans les labos on voit des centaines
de français faire la queue universités
mais même dans les ehpad il faudrait
tester préventivement et les personnes
qui ont l'intention de se rendre dans
les ehpad donc c'est toute une politique
et ça va être la clé du deuxième
déconfinement ça va être la triste aussi
mais parce que pour l'instant on ne scie
n'est pas vraiment on a l'impression
qu'on attend on attend finalement que le
marché comme ça bizarrement où se
trouvent les solutions médianes c'était
pas ça qui marchait il faut un état
stratège il faut une véritable gestion
de crise et aujourd'hui gouvernement
dans cette on est quand même
effaré de voir que huit mois qu'on a
l'impression d'être au même point en
tout cas voilà moi j'ai avec mes
collègues on a le sentiment de servir un
peu de paillasson parce que finalement
mal géré la crise
donc oui elle soutient aujourd'hui le
compliment parce qu'il n'a pas le choix
parce que à un moment donné il faut
ralentir les contacts physiques entre
les gens parce que nous n'arrivons pas à
prendre en charge autant de patients
avec nos passions habituel il s'appelle
on est déjà débordé en permanence toute
l'année quand il ya un long week-end des
vacances les épidémies hivernales donc
là le coc vide en plus avec le poids de
ces 35 milliards qu'on a eue sur la sur
la première vague
évidemment on ne veut pas revivre des
situations où nous ne pouvons rien faire
donc on est obligé de ralentir obligé
d'accepter le confinement de le soutenir
mais c'est à notre corps défendant parce
que on peut faire autrement et il faut
c'est le trou en l'état actuel des
capacités humaines et et de lits dans
l'est dans les hôpitaux une meilleure
organisation des services mhcs dit on
pourrait alléger en tout cas quelque peu
le travail des soignants notamment les
médecins réanimateurs on pourrait au
mieux disputer avec des gens un peu
moins expérimentés pour les aider ça me
saoule et je vous le dis tel quel
d'entendre en permanence ce gouvernement
vous parler de leur organisation
ce sont des besoins humains désormais il
faut des gens pour travailler
moi je l'écris comme toute provocation
la réponse d'emmanuel bako aux soignants
sur un hôpital parisien qui le lui
demander des moyens il aurait dit c'est
une question de moyens c'est une
question d'organisation
on entendait déjà sassou que la
sarkozyste et son discours d'alsace
depuis ils nous répètent les mêmes et
les mêmes choses nous en sommes au xxi
ème réorganisation aujourd'hui sinon ce
sont des moyens des moyens matériels et
techniques parce que nous n'avons pas de
matériel en nombre suffisant on l'a vu
au début de cette épidémie et surtout
des moyens humains et je le dis oui il
faut commencer un grand plan de
formation et de recrutement parce que
nous sommes fatigués les soignants sont
fatigués et tout de suite il faut
embaucher des gens qui peuvent les
soulager en termes logistiques
administratifs qui occupe pour
l'administratif une grande part de notre
activité
recentrons nous sur le coeur de métier
après oui on peut toujours faire du
bricolage ça on a réussi à le faire
c'est au détriment de la santé et de la
motivation des soignants parce qu'à un
moment donné on a besoin d'un véritable
choc d'attractivité pour rattraper les
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont quitté l'hopital public mais pour le
faire il va falloir leur proposer des
revenus et des conditions de travail
autre que celle qu aujourd'hui on subit
et à quel prix puisque la conséquence
est évidemment ce confinement qui pèse
aussi beaucoup sur la santé des français
moral notamment et économique qui peut
être catastrophique en tout cas pour la
santé des français
c'est la démonstration avec le premier
confinement on a récupéré l'enjeu je
vais rester sur la médecine je ne parle
même pas des catastrophes sociales que
ça engendre parce que on dit bao mais
les gens au chômage partiel oui mais
quand on est des petits salaires
perdre plus de 10% de ses revenus ça se
sent la famille et puis sur le plan
médical on a vu arriver des gens
extrêmement des cris on a raté des gens
qu'on fait des problèmes cardiaques qui
ne vont pas appeler on a vu ensuite
deuxième mini vague après la sortie de
confinement pendant de déconfinement de
gens qui s'étaient dégradées qui ne les
suivent ils ont fait leurs soins qui
n'avait pas été pris en charge et des
compensations psychiatrique qu'on
sous-estimé souvent parce que ce
confinement sa table aussi sur lumière
et on a des gens oui qui ont développé
des pathologies psychiatriques d'amboise
le christ de très courts qu'est ce que
vous répondez l'exécutif quand il dit
que c'est pas mieux ailleurs qu'en
europe qui sont aussi en train de re en
confinant alors je réponds enfin que
c'est marrant mais partout en europe on
a une politique néolibérale identique
évidemment les mêmes politiques
produisent les mêmes effets mais on en a
un peu le propos en france parce que
l'allemagne est quand même c'est
beaucoup beaucoup sur sa capacité de
prise en charge des malades de kovy
données sans taux de mortalité est
moindre
il ya d'autres pays qui peuvent encore
exister en exemples pareils mais moi je
n'entends pas parler de confinement ou
chine
quand je vois un grand soutien de la
chine sur sa politique en général mais
sur la capacité qu'ils ont eu tout de
suite réagir aux résurgence du virus
on a eu la même chose en nouvelle
zélande on a eu la même chose en corée
du sud
ce sont des gens qui ont décidé aussi
être plus interventionniste de fer que
l'état soit stratège est à re que la
collectivité prenne la main et qu'on ne
laisse pas le marché finalement décider
de ce qu'il est capable de faire une
politique de santé publique
merci beaucoup d'eau et peine d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions en
direct sur arte france